hello chess fans I'm Sam Copeland and
I'm a national master on the content
team here at chess comm and I'm here
today to show you an incredible computer
chess game in the 13th season of the
computer Chess Championship Leela chess
zero defeated stockfish with 106 points
out of a possible 200 in this game we
see an incredible understanding of space
from Leela and the ability with a flood
of pawns on the King side to create near
zugzwang in the middle game the first
two moves are actually given by the
opening books used for the competition
c4 and a six but from here the engines
are thinking for themselves we see
natural moves from both engines for the
first few moves but we do have something
that stands out to me
it is Queen b6 in this position at from
stockfish humans have actually liked to
play pawn d5 instead I think we're onto
something as this seems a much more
natural move than Queen to b6 which
never seems to fit into any part of a
coherent plan from stockfish after Queen
to b6 we see both of the engines kind of
develop without creating initial crises
in the middle of the board and
eventually Leela makes a bid for an
initiative here as it expands with pawn
to b4 now in this position you don't
have to be a super high-level engine to
appreciate that capturing the pawn is
bad C takes b4 destabilizes this knight
and loses central control now Knight a4
queen a7 to defend the knight Knight
puts pressure on the pin knight on d4
and after you defend it I'm going to win
my pawn back and I've made significant
positional gains of course stockfish is
not going to fall for this and after
pawn to b4 it pulls its Queen back to c7
begging the question why was your queen
on b6 in any case after Queen c7 we see
pawn to a4 pushing forward on one wing
and then pawn to f4 pushing forward on
the other wing these are the beginnings
of what is a clear space gaining
strategy from Leela the neural networks
have in general been very very effective
with space gaining plans after pawn to
f4 the knight pulls back to c6 we get a
trade here on c5 e 5
for it in the middle of the board Bishop
e7 King h2 no idea what that's about
if you know pushed in the comments rook
b8 Knight f3 we see a trade here the
Queen captures back and rook d8 now I
think it's interesting to pause here for
a moment and ask what both engines think
they have I think Lila clearly values
its extra space and mobility for its
pieces presumably stockfish seems to be
appreciating the positional Trump's here
like a half opened e-file like a
pressure on a backwards pawn on d3 like
outpost here for the night
I think something that neural networks
have demonstrated repeatedly against the
more traditional engines is that more
space and control of the position
Trump's these positional concerns that's
certainly true in this game as blacks
very very cramped pieces that lack scope
are not able to generate effective
counter play against the weak positional
parts of the white position and
meanwhile the space and control clearly
begins to expand and become an
overwhelming factor in the game as we
see things develop in any case after
rook d2 we see Queenie to b6
Knight in to e4 Knight before what are
you going to do about the attack here on
d3 I think the answer is the first
brilliant move in this game from Leela
Bishop to d2 this is a really wonderful
idea that really gets the plan of
expansion rolling from Leela we're now
going to try and take this Knight and
push our pawns forward in the middle of
the board and the big question is why
can't you capture here on d3 well rook
takes d3 is pretty clearly bad we're
gonna take on before and York is loose
that's a beginner error it's certainly
not an error and engine would make
Knight takes D 3 though is more
complicated why can't you capture here
there's no direct tactical refutation
but after Bishop c3 the idea of f5 seems
to be just too strong if you ignore the
possibility of pawned
five and play and move like Bishop d7
when I push forward here you can have
another pawn you're up two points down
good for you
we're going to push forward with f6 we
are going to shatter your control of the
dark squares I will attack f7 and now in
this position it seems very hard to
defend as black because I have total
control that are squares and h4 h5 is a
really really strong idea if you tried
to stop pawn to f5 when I played Bishop
c3 and you played g6 then I can do
something different I could attack your
knight and then I can go Knight f6 check
if you move over I'm already ready to
open up a tremendous attack by pushing
pawn to f5 with ideas of opening amazing
attacking lines to your king and if you
take my knight then I'm going to put the
bishop on e5 and that's going to also be
a nightmare for black in fact this
position should just be winning so all
of that to say after we play this
Riemann over here with Bishop d2 it's
not possible to capture on d3 and since
it's not possible blacks strategy has
essentially failed white is now going to
be expanding and demonstrating a clear
advantage in the game after pawn to d4
another nice strategy supported by clean
tactics I'm expanding here and you can't
take my pawn because I will trap your
queen in the middle of the board I like
how the knight controls the Queen's
escape squares on the C file beautiful
domination so after I push forward with
Ponty for I have ideas of d5 I have
ideas of f5 what are you going to do the
engine chose Bishop to b7 here rook B to
d1 continuing to play with the idea of
expansion Bishop c6 going after a4 which
is pretty greedy rook d2 Bishop takes a4
and from here I think we're seeing some
really sophisticated play that totally
neutralizes any attempts from stockfish
for counter play we see rook a 1 first
rook d2 c8 pawn to d5 notice how the
white pawns dominate this bishop in
particular but really all of the black
pieces are very much lacking scope in
this position rooked
Bishop to b3 attacking c4 work to c1
defending it Bishop back to a four here
and rook to b1
I think this move in particular is
really brilliant and sophisticated it
passes the move to black says what are
you going to do and the engine doesn't
seem to have any answer after pawn to a5
in this position I think it is very
difficult for black to make any progress
over on the Queen side or really to gain
significant scope for the black pieces
that means that white is going to expand
with the pawns on the King side in a
tremendous way and it turns out that
stockfish just doesn't have a way to
respond to that
this really really deep strategy is also
supported by some nice tactics for
example in this position after Leela
launches forward with h4 beginning this
strategy if you play b5 trying to get
things rolling on the Queen side then
Bishop h3 threatening to capture here is
already really really strong after h4 we
see a sad movie we need maybe you're
gonna have to pull back here to hold on
against Bishop h3 d6 attacking the
bishop bishop d8 and g4 I'm continuing
to expand and you still can't try and
push forward over here if you do this
time then you've shut off your Bishop
and you are forked so the pawns are
expanding again g4 bishop c6 pulling
that bishop back but again after you
pull that Bishop back how are you going
to push forward you'll drop this pawn if
you push the a pawn if you push this
you're just dropping it right away there
still is not a good plan for counter
play h5 moving up the board black plays
the sad move King to h8 but I can't
recommend anything much better if you
play b5 now I play pawn to c5 and I'm
just establishing huge pawns in the
position so we do see that move King h8
g5 Queen of fate rook F 1 preparing pawn
to f5 and all four of our Center and
King side pawns here are on the fifth
rank let's just pause and appreciate
that beautiful achievement from Leela
having achieved this there are now big
threats in the position of course like
capturing on e6 or pushing forward
further with the pawns so there is no
choice for stockfish you must capture on
f5 and after rope takes f5 Bishop d7 it
actually looks like White has gone too
far
of course if you can't press home your
attack eventually the king will become a
problem and black is now threatening the
rook thinking about the possibility of
putting the bishop on e6 and also
attacking the c4 pawn a couple of times
how is white to continue here probably
the finest move of the game is Queen to
f1 boom a great move this sacrifices an
exchange but it is the critical move to
further the attack and keep everything
rolling in the face of all these threats
there's no good way to just sit tight
so black does capture here Bishop takes
out five Queen takes f5 and black needs
to capture on c4 you have two choices
let's look quickly at both of them in
the game be take c4 is played so we're
starting here with rook takes c4 rook
takes c4 g6 pushing forward you have a
pin on the F pawn so now pawn to b3 just
trying to make progress on the Queen
side before white gets there on the
Queen side pawn forward up to e6 rook c2
trying to create pressure here and get
this pawn further up the board Queen
takes f7 you can't really trade Queens
because I will have three connected
passed pawns very close to queening
Bishop h4 so that this defends right
here pawn to e7 Queen over to g8 rook d1
keeping control over this and now after
b2 I love the move here Queen to f4 a
fantastic winning move that traps this
Bishop and also stops this rook from
growing from going forward to c1 to help
promote this pawn it turns out there's
no defense here for black white is
winning in this position and these pawns
are just too much they are stronger than
the stopped pawn on b2 so
in the game after Queen takes f5
stockfish with that extra exchange
captured on c4 and in addition to its
extra exchange it now has three
connected pass pawns that look very
dangerous on the Queen side but Lila's
position is the stronger one d7
attacking the rook the rook moves Knight
to d6 this creates a huge threat on f7
it also opens up a discovered attack
against the rook
so that must sacrifice itself rook takes
d 6 e takes d 6 we do see now that White
has the exchange back but still we are
down to pawns and the pawns look
dangerous over here but our attack is
much the stronger we're looking to
invade on the e-file we also have ideas
of Bishop e4 with a tremendous battery
and there's no defense for black let's
see why in some critical lines if you
push forward and attack the rook then
after rook e 2 you can capture on d6
with check your now up a full three
pawns but after king h3 this is a
monster threat and after Bishop e7 to
prevent me getting to e8 simply Queen d5
overwhelms stockfish there's no way to
hold against the simple idea of trading
Queens and invading on e8 in this
position amazing stuff so after we
capture here it is Bishop to b6 that's
played and there is only one winning
move here it is King h3 I know you guys
you guys all saw that one right King h3
easy easy move the thing about King h3
is we are simply getting ready to bring
our rook in without allowing this pawn
to fall with a check and we're also
making sure that we pick a square that
is safe for our King not a square on the
back rank where we could get checked by
a promoting pawn that will be critical
in some lines so in this position we see
a passive and losing defense from
stockfish but let's ask what happens if
you try to push for it and just get
these pawns to the other side of the
board
rook e - here we are invading too
quickly here b3 rook to e7 c2 and now if
you just keep pushing forward here
Bishop b4 attacking the square here on
h7 g6 Queen f6 check King over and a
quiet move Bishop to d5 you may have a
queen but I will take f7 I will force
checkmate is in fact mate in three moves
here no way to defend against the
collapse here on f7 also notice the
importance of the opposite opposite
colored bishops here to the white attack
that is a new strategic theme that has
emerged if you were to play a little
more defensively after the rook came
into e7 and stopped trying to push the
pawns and play to move like Bishop d4
trying to hold the dark squares together
we still break through as white Bishop
b4 threatening mate g6 here and now we
don't have this move that was so great
just a moment ago but we can trade on g6
and win the game if you take with the F
pawn we get a nice finish
we sack a ruck and we mate here on 8 7
and if you take with the H pawn over
here simply Queen f4 we have too much
going against f7 it is not just an f7
pawn winning attack it is basically a
mating attack but cannot hold against
the threats so after King h3 we see what
I think is basically resignation from
stockfish that is the move Queen to g8
the saddest move I have seen an engine
play in some time Bishop to d5 attacking
f7 rook to f8 I don't think I need to
tell you that the strategy of burying
all of your important pieces in the
corner of the board is not generally a
winning strategy pawn to g6 we've got a
pin here pawn to h6 we take the Queen is
basically trapped she has to go over 287
and we just clamped down with Queen to
g6 there is no defense for black to the
invasion of the rook on the e8 square
but there's no resignation in the
computer chess championship you play to
mate and the mate we play to is this one
right here I hope you've enjoyed this
computer game I think it is fascinating
rich and instructive and beautiful if
you like this game then do click on the
playlists' on top of the board at four
more game of the day playlists and for
more computer chess playlists